und jetzt das heute
journal guten Abend dem heiligen
Nikolaus wird ja unter anderem das
sogenannte kornwunder zugeschrieben er
überredete Seeleute einen Teil der
Getreideladung ihres Schiffes für
notleidende zu spenden und siee da als
das Schiff danach weiterfuhr hatte seine
Ladung trotz der Entnahme kein Gramm
Gewicht
verloren noluse gab es heute am Kabinett
auch aber kein kornwunder die
Haushaltslöcher sind immer noch da und
der Streit darüber wie man das Problem
fürs nächste Jahr lösen will auch
vielleicht gelingt das jetzt am Abend da
treffen sich noch mal Scholz Harbeck und
Lindner im
katzlerabend dort steht für uns Diana
Zimmermann Diana wird das wieder mal
eine lange Berliner Nacht oder was was
hörst
du ich höre nichts und würde das als
Zeichen dafürwererten dass hier hinter
mir sehr konzentriert gearbeitet wird
ähm den ganzen Tag wurde verhandelt
zwischen Kanzler Wirtschafts und
Finanzminister und bis auf eine kurze
Pause in der Olaf Scholz den belgischen
König empfing wird jetzt seit 6:30 Uhr
etwa weiter verhandelt die letzten
Wochen haben wir sehr viel gehört von
den Koalitionsspitzen vor allen Dingen
Vorschläge wo die jeweils beiden anderen
Parteien doch bitte sparen sollten und
worauf sie verzichten sollten heute war
es sehr still das spricht dafür dass man
nun tatsächlich an Kompromissen arbeitet
und nichts anderes kann man ja auch
eigentlich von einer demokratisch
gewählten Regierung erwarten solange
dieser Haushalt 24 nicht steht nämlich
gibt es viele Bürger und Unternehmen im
Land die Sorgen haben die keine
Planungssicherheit haben und das ist
deswegen kritisch weil es eben
tatsächlich darum geht welche
Fördersummen welche Kredite der Bund im
nächsten Jahr auflegen kann das ist ähm
eine Belastung für Deutschland für den
Wirtschaftsstandort es ist eine
Belastung für die Ampel die am Samstag
Halbzeit begeht und es ist eine
Belastung für den Kanzler der am
Wochenende einen SPD Parteitag vor sich
hat und da möchte er ganz sicher nicht
als ein Kanzler ohne Haushalt sondern
als ein Kanzler mit Plan dastehen die
Einschätzung aus Berlin danke schön
Diana Wladimir Putin reiste heute in die
Golfregion besuchte die Vereinigten
Arabischen Emirate und Saudi-Arabien
eine Verhaftung hatte er nicht zu
befürchten die beiden Länder sind keine
Vertragsparteien des Internationalen
Strafgerichtshofs stattdessen gab es
einen Empfang mit viel Pomp Staffel und
roten Teppich was ihm sicher gefallen
hat der Mann kommt ja nicht mehr viel
herum in der Welt und es dürfte ihm auch
recht sein wenn sein Auftritt am Golf
etwas ablenkt von der im benachbarten
Emirat Dubai stattfindenden
Weltklimakonferenz bei der ist jetzt
auch Halbzeit und Andreas Stamm zieht
für uns eine
Zwischenbilanz eine globale Party ist es
noch nicht angeführt vom koppräsidenten
der als Ölmanager heftig kritisiert
kommt die Weltklimakonferenz in
Trippelschritten voran Sultan aljaber
sucht Kompromisse bei dem Thema kann in
Dubai der Abschied von Ölkohle Gas
beschlossen werden die Zeit drängt den
2023 werde das global heißeste je
gemessene Jahr laut dem EU
klimawandeldienst liegt die
Durchschnittstemperatur bislang um 1,46°
höher als vor der Industrialisierung
noch ein Ausnahmejahr aber ein weiterer
wegruf für die
Weltklimakonferenz wenn man sich die
tatsächlichen Pläne der Regierungen
schaut stellt man fest dass bis zum Jahr
2030 die Kohleproduktion steigen soll
und dann erst langsam abflacht bis zum
Jahr 2050 soll die Öl und Gasproduktion
steigen und dann vielleicht ein Plateau
erreichen das ist mit einem 1,5° pfahrt
in keiner Weise vereinbar bei einem
Punkt gab es Überraschungen an Tag 1
wird ein Fond für Klimaschäden
eingerichtet eine Jahrzehnte alte
Forderung der Entwicklungsländer
mittlerweile urteilen Aktivisten und
Experten härter Überraschung gelungen
aber eine zu kleine die Schäden durch
die Klimawandelfolgen gehen in die
Milliarden nicht Millionen dazu ein
koppräsidente erzählt dass es keinen
wissenschaftlichen Beleg gebe dass wir
weg vom Öl müssen danach sagte die
Wissenschaft würde ihn leiten um das
1,5° Ziel am Leben zu erhalten was für
ein
Durcheinander über den Erfolg der
Konferenz entscheidet vor allem wie weit
kommt man beim fossilen Ausstieg
garantiert ist für die zweite Halbzeit
nur eins ein Tage und nächtelanger
Verhandlungsmarathon das der
Nahostkonflikt massiv polarisiert dass
Hass auf Israel und Antisemitismus weit
verbreitet sind das war alles nicht neu
aber an manchen Orten brach das in den
letzten Wochen in einer Weise auf mit
der nicht jeder gerechnet hatte das an
berühmten amerikanischen
Eliteuniversitäten bereits am Tag der
hamassangriffe in öffentlichen
Bekundungen der Terror noch nicht mal
als solcher benannt wurde das war nicht
nur für die jüdischen Studierenden dort
ein Schock sie erlebt en Übergriffe und
Hassparolen an und in den
Universitäten dazu gab es jetzt im
US-Kongress eine Anhörung die nun
wiederum hohe Wellen schlägt aus
Washington Claudia
Bates der Bildungsausschuss des
Repräsentantenhauses forderte klare
Antworten doch die Präsidentinnen der
Eliteuniversitäten antworteten
akademisch differenziert und blieben
auch da im Ungefähren wo es den
Fragenden Abgeordneten weh tat
verstößt der Aufruf zum Völkermord in
Harvard gegen Richtlinien zu Mobbing und
Belästigung ja oder
nein das hängt vom Kontext
ab welchem
Kontext ob jemand gezielt als
Einzelperson angegriffen
wird ich denke mindestens ist es
Hassrede und sollte verurteilt werden ob
es einem Aufruf zu Gewalt gleich kommt
unter den Grundsätzen denen die
penuniversität folgt und die geleitet
sind von der Verfassung das ist eine
viel schwierigere
Frage radikale propalästinensische
sprechköre Israel werden
Kriegsverbrechen Kolonialismus und
Völkermord vorgeworfen wie hier an der
Harvard Universität bei einer Einladung
in den Kongress berichten jüdische
Studenten von
Bedrohungen ich HRE ru Juden zu verasen
hätte recht
gehabt Studenten und Professoren riefen
stolz zum Völkermord an Juden auf die
unipräsidentinnen Verurteilten
Antisemitismus klar und deutlich
aber wir sind verpflichtet die freie
Meinungsäußerung zu schützen auch bei
Ansichten die wir ablehnen oder
beleidigend
finden Grenzen ziehen sie erst bei
direkten persönlichen Übergriffen oder
Gewalt mit dem Kriegsgeschehen im Nahen
Osten geht das jetzt bei dir weiter
gundela ja im Gazastreifen läuft eine
der schwersten kampffphasen seit Beginn
des Krieges vor zwei Monaten die
israelische Armee attackiert massiv die
Hamas Hochburg ranunis zugleich
verschärft sich die humanitäre Lage in
südgasa 1,9 Millionen Binnenvertriebene
haben immer weniger sichere Räume und
sind in Not zwei Moskau Treue Politiker
aus der Ukraine sind durch Anschläge
getötet worden im Fall Ilia Kiva soll
sich der ukrainische Geheimdienst zu der
Tat bekannt haben in Kiev ehrte
Präsident selenski am Tag der
Streitkräfte schwer verletzte Soldaten
und erwies gefallenen Ukrainern die
letzte
Ehre Bahnkunden müssen sich auf einen
weiteren Warnstreik einstellen die
Gewerkschaft der Lockführer hat zu einem
eintägigen Ausstand aufgerufen von
morgen abend 22 Uhr bis Freitag Abend
damit wird auch der Wochenendverkehr
beeinträchtigt Ende November hatte die
GDL die Tarifverhandlungen mit der Bahn
abgebrochen im Bundestag gibt es nur
noch fünf Fraktionen nach der heute
wirksam gewordenen Selbstauflösung der
Linksfraktion wollen die verbliebenen 28
Abgeordneten als Gruppe weiter linke
Oppositionsarbeit leisten hintergrund
ist die Abspaltung von Sara Wagenknecht
der sich neun Abgeordnete der Linken
angeschoss
ein Berliner Urgestein der Grünen ist
verstorben Wolfgang Wieland 1988 hatte
er die Alternative Liste Berlin
mitbegründet ein Vorläufer von Bündnis
90 die Grünen Wieland kurzzeitig auch
Justizsenator von Berlin wurde 75 Jahre
alt und wir haben die gewinnzahlen vom
Lotto am Mittwoch sie lauten 2 15 27 42
43 45
Superzahl 1 weitere Gewinnzahlen auf
Lotto zdf.de und im ZDF Text das
Winterwetter wird wieder milder etwas
Schnee oder Regen gibt es im Osten sonst
teils neblig drübe oder bewölkt teils
freundlich mit längerem Sonnenschein 0
bis 6° am Freitag von Westen her Schnee
und Glatteisregen der bis Samstag den
Südosten erreicht danach deutlich milder
wechselhaft und
windig das war's von uns gleich geht's
mit der zweiten Halbzeit weiter und um
0:45 Uhr meldet sich Christopher wehmann
mit unserem Update Wiedersehen
[Musik]
tschüss